Good morning John!
So here's a thing that I don't think Nerdfighters
need to be told, but maybe you know, subconsciously
even if you don't think about it, because
I don't really think about it but it's definitely
a choice I make every single video.
Some videos I make because I want as many
people as possible to see them.
Whether that's to get a lot of views because
it feels good, or to grow the community, or
to convey an idea that I feel like more people
need to have in their heads.
And some videos are just for Nerdfighters.
Just for the people who are gonna watch no
matter what, as long as I don't just sit here
and do nothing for four minutes.
And I gotta say, I really like those videos.
I like not having the pressure; I like just
being able to talk about what's in my head.
Also this community has given me so many wonderful
gifts; I like to give you guys gifts back.
I'll do a lot of things for you guys.
Do you wanna see me lick a battery?
A-AH-Ahhh.
I connected the positive and the negative.
Science.
[distorted voice] Maybe it'd be better if
I just made the entire video with this thing!
Probably not.
[spitting noise]
It's weird to feel in debt to a lot of people
and not know how to pay that debt back.
One of the ways I feel like I could do it
is just to make videos for you that nobody
else is gonna see and it's clearly just for
the people who've been so supportive of us.
And also I feel like it's good th--to like
define what the community of Nerdfighteria
is every once in a while, 'cause I think some
people don't really understand.
I mean I don't think that anybody really understands
it.
But I did just get an ask from somebody on
Tumblr who said that they'd been shamed in
a Nerdfighter community for being transgender,
and, like, what?
I don't know how someone could feel like that's
the kinda thing a Nerdfighter would do, but
it's not.
That's--you're--that's not a Ner--that's not
a Nerdfighter.
So sometimes I worry about what this all is
and that people are doing the wrong things
in the name of the thing, and not understanding
the thing.
And I also worry about the decoupling of productivity
and wages.
Productivity is just all the benefits to humans
that the economy creates.
And wages, of course, are the money that people
make.
And they used to be things that were really
closely tied together, and now... they're
not anymore.
I'm worried about what this means for our
society: that the rich are just gonna get
richer, and that the poor aren't gonna benefit,
and it's gonna create instability as well
as suffering.
And I'm also worried about what the world's
gonna look like if we're able to create lots
of cool services for people, and they're gonna
be so cheap that maybe people don't even need
to pay for them, like, what does that world
look like?
I wanna make a video on this topic, a video
that lots of people, not just Nerdfighters
would watch...
But I'm no econonomist, so I gotta do a bunch
of research and learn stuff...
Like, like how to pronounce econonomist.
Also, VidCon's coming up.
I'm not worried about VidCon in general.
There's lots of cool things that--like amazing
things that're gonna happen at VidCon, like,
it's gonna be a good time.
But we're having this meet-and-greet lottery
thing, if you wanna go to--into the signing
hall and get any signings or pictures and
anything you gotta do the lottery, you gotta
rank all your favorite creators, how much
you like them and then the system assigns
you meet-and-greets.
And if you don't do the lottery thing, you
don't get any.
And so far only about half of people who have
registered have signed up for the lottery,
and that terrifies me, because I feel like,
maybe they just don't know it's a thing.
And maybe I'm living in this old-person world
where people check their email, and they don't
check their email, and I don't know how to
get in touch with people who don't check their
email!
So I'm worried about people showing up at
VidCon and being very disappointed because
they did not sign up for the lottery.... but
I don't know what to do about that problem.
So those are some things I've been worried
about...
Here's some things I'm excited about!
I produce multiple YouTube shows and what
producing means, I'm not really sure.
One of those shows is called How To Adult,
which is fairly self-explanatory.
And it's very useful, even for me, a guy who's
been adult-ing for, like, 15 years.
How To Adult is launching its Patreon page
today to help pay for its existence, so if
you're interested in learning "how to adult,"
or you already like How To Adult and you wanna
help them continue making cool stuff...
You can check that stuff out, link's in the
description.
I'm also producing a new show with Charlie
McDonnell, uh, called Cereal Time.
It's a morning show, five days a week.
It's a lot like Good Mythical Morning, but
it's more British.
And I'm excited about doing more things with
Nerdfighteria.
Doin' stuff together.
Like, I--I wanna do a scavenger hunt.
So I'm gonna be thinkin' about that.
And maybe you can help.
But I'm not gonna tell you how to help, cause
I already did.
Thank you to all the people who watched this
video because I know that you are among the
people who watch them no matter what, every
single one, and that means a lot to me.
Thanks... for being a part of this!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.